thank you bob it's it's really quite an
honor to
be invited here for this purpose not
only because of the
award in itself but because of the
really highly esteemed colleagues who
participated in granting this this this
great honor
um i i think bob's uh introduction
essentially covers my talk so i think we
can all go to the break now
but maybe i'll give you a few details
instead so
that we can just start by thinking about
what
the what one knows about the processing
mechanisms
in vision occurring at the very earliest
stages of cortical visual processing
and over the the talk i want to develop
you
for you a theme that beyond the fairly
simple feed forward properties that were
described by
torsten wiesel and david hubel many
years ago
we are now learning that the response
properties of neurons and the
the the function of neurons is actually
much more complex
even at the very earliest stages of
processing
secondly that this complexity is in part
uh defined not only by intrinsic
connections within a cortical area
which relate to this idea of the
association field but
they are subject to top-down influences
of attention
expectation perceptual task and
efference copy so
neurons do not have a fixed functional
role but are constantly doing
switching of their function on a
moment-to-moment basis
as we engage different uh different
tasks and different
objects in our environment and finally
the the
we know that experience can shape these
properties
as a result of on
ongoing interaction with the world and
that we can see the effects of
alterations in visual experience
in in these circuits that exist within
the visual cortex and in the functional
properties of
neurons and in particular we look at an
aspect of learning and memory
known as perceptual learning which we
think actually involves
the neurons in the primary visual cortex
among other areas and someone has to
think of
the cerebral cortex as a whole as a
learning engine capable
of incorporating new strategies as we
continue to experience the world so to
begin with
uh we know from the the early work that
neurons have
receptor fields that are tiny windows on
the world
uh within which a stimulus will cause
the neuron to fire and
depending on in the in the primary
visual cortex depending on
where the receptor field is relative to
the center of gaze
you can have very tiny receptor fields
near the center of gaze and they get
progressively larger as you go away
and so that defines the center of region
of the neurons but i will
i will develop for you the idea that in
fact neurons are sensitive to visual
stimuli
extending over much larger regions when
you design the visual stimulus
appropriately but within the receptor
field it's known that the
that a simple stimulus such as a single
oriented line segment
presented on the correct orientation
will cause the neuron to fire
and then as you change the orientation
the response gets progressively less
so this then would imply that
we take an image and break it up into a
series of short oriented line segments
that describes the contour boundary of
that object
but that begs the question of how we
assemble these these elements
into a unified percept of the global
contour of the shape of this teddy bear
so one might have thought that this
happens progressively
over a hierarchy of cortical areas going
from the early visual cortex
on into the temporal lobe where you have
neurons that are selective for
objects as complex as faces but what
we've been learning
is that even back at these earliest
stages in the primary visual cortex
neurons are integrating much more
complex aspects of the visual
environment and are integrating
aspects of contours that extend well
outside the receptive field
which it sort of seems to be something
of a contradiction in terms because what
is the receptor field except for the
area
of the sensory map where the neuron
receives input
well the resolution comes in the
difference between what we see when we
use a simple stimulus to map this
receptive field such as a single
oriented line segment so here if we put
a a line here you'll get a certain
response you put a line outside this
region you get zero response
but when you use a more complex stimulus
such as putting two line segments into
alignment with each other
then you find that you can get a
response that is two or three times the
response of the neuron as
with that from what you get with this
this simple line segment within the
receptive field center
if you then do something to break the
continuity between those two lines
you no longer get that sort of
facilitation
so
this we think relates to a
general property of how we analyze the
visual image
which was originally described by the
gestalt psychologists early in the 20th
century
and what they what they noted
particularly the work of max wertheimer
was that there were certain rules by
which we group stimuli in the visual
scene
both the similarity proximity
and a property that he referred to as
good continuation
and that is that if we make a contour
where the there is relatively
uh smoothness in the in the contour
element so
we tend to link this contour element
with that one as belonging to the same
contour
whereas this and this seem to belong to
different contours
so that simplifies greatly the problem
for how we parse the visual image there
may be
a nearly infinite number of possible
combinations of line segments within a
complex image such as what i'm looking
at it now
but we actually simplify it by only
linking the elements
that have this characteristic smoothness
of contours
and this can also be expressed more
geometrically
by a concept that we call collinearity
or co-circularity
and that is that object contours are
relatively smooth they don't take on
sort of fractal characteristics
so if there is a straight line within an
image it tends to be
kept straight for long distances if
there's a curve contour it tends to
maintain the same radius of curvature
and so at the level of the visual cortex
this describes the property of the
association field
so you might have a cell whose receptor
field is
within this region but it sets up
a a range of interactions across the
cortical map
where it links con the the contour
elements that are
collinear or co-circular with it and
this can also account
for a property that uh of the contour
saliency so i actually should back up to
point out this one
where if you take a relatively smooth
contour
and vet it in a complex background it
will pop out quite readily from that
background
but if you have a contour where there's
much more jumble in the relative
orientation of the consecutive line
elements
and put that into such a background you
can't see it it won't pop out
i mean you can eventually find it
through serial search but it's much more
difficult
and this is reflected in the properties
of neurons in the visual cortex
as you can determine by having an animal
trained
to fixate a spot of light in the center
of the
of the of the of the screen and you
present these two patches
of randomly oriented lines and the task
for the animal
is to make a cod towards the patch that
contains
this embedded salient contour and we can
look at how the responses of neurons
and the superficial layers of the visual
cortex uh
are affected by the presence of this
embedded contour so we can either
look at what happens when you just have
a single line element within
the receptive field of the receptor
wheels orientation
or this line of collinear contour
segments as
we put it either within the receptor
field or in the opposite hemi field
and so what this what we find is that as
we increase the number of lines
that we put into alignment and putting
into this sort of background
you get a progressively stronger
response from the neuron so
there's a considerable counter-related
facilitation so we will call this the
contour
related response and so the the so even
in v1 in the primary visual cortex the
responsive neurons
are as dependent on the global
characteristics of contours that extend
well outside
the receptor field as they are on the
attribute of the line segment that is
presented in the receptor field center
also it's it's nice to point out that we
know that there are inhibitory
influences surrounding the receptive
field and so
generally when we are looking at uh
complex images
all of the stuff in the cer in the
surround will suppress the response of
the neuron
so that sort of begs the question of how
neurons would respond at all
if we if we're always looking at complex
scenes and this shows you how
this how it happens and that the
the the global characteristics of the
contour are
make it possible to lift the neuron out
of the
of this inhibition so this is the
response of an oriental line presented
in isolation
this is what it responds to when the
line is presented with the background
but then you get much less of this
inhibition when you have this collinear
contour
so we've been interested in thinking
about the mechanisms of cortical
processing
in terms of the circuitry within the
cortex and
this raises the the finding that we had
early on so this is from the work that i
did with torso weasel
many years ago where we discovered a
class of connections within the visual
cortex and now this has been found to
exist
in every cortical region whereby neurons
can
link activity across
wide swaths of cortical territory so if
you look at this neuron this is one
where we recorded intracellularly from
it and then
injected it with a dye that spread
throughout the dendritic and axonal
larva so this is the dendrite of the
neuron
and all of the rest of this is the axon
of the neuron which goes from
the axon hillock at the bottom of the
neuron and then branches many times
extending for long distances parallel to
the cortical surface
and what this means is that since the
there is a visual topic map
on the cortical surface what this means
is that a cell over here
is integrating information over an area
of cortex
that represents an area of visual space
much larger
than its so-called classical receptor
field
so we think this can account for these
rather higher order integrative
properties of cortical neurons
one reason that to support this is in
this curious clustering behavior of the
axon collaterals
and so we can look at how this relates
to the functional architecture of cortex
by doing an experiment where we label a
population of these horizontally
projecting neurons and and compare that
to the pattern of orientation columns on
the cortical surface
so what we do is we can use a
viral vector to infect the neuron and
transfer the gene encoding the green
fluorescent protein
into the neurons so that the neuron
synthesizes tons of this fluorescent
label
which spreads throughout its dendritic
and axonal arbor so this is from an
experiment where we
labeled about 6 000 neurons and now
you're looking down on the cortical
surface
through a confocal microscope and you
can see this pattern of projections
where it's it gets uh you can see these
clustered
axon collaterals and when you
superimpose that
on the orientation map so keep in mind
that while neurons
have the preference for orientation
there are groups of neurons extending
from the cortical surface down to the
white matter
that share the same orientation
preference as you go across the cortical
surface there's a regular clockwise or
counterclockwise shift
in orientation preference so this is a
false color image obtained with
a technique known as intrinsic signal
optical imaging
where the different colors represent the
different orientations so
here we've made the injection in an
orientation column representing
uh horizontal and
the the black lines are the
reconstructions of the axon collaterals
extending from the injection site
so within the short distance these axon
collaterals contact
orientation columns of the full range of
orientations
but as you get farther away say about
500 microns away from the
injection site you see this this
clustering behavior that mediates
connectivity between columns of similar
orientation preference
as this is shown by this histogram so
this then
uh adheres to one of the rules of good
continuation this sort of like to like
connectivity between columns of similar
orientation preference
and it also uh obeys the
the extent of these lateral interactions
so if you do psychophysical experiments
looking at the
the distance over which these
interactions can occur
if you make a contour where there's a
certain uh
where you change the spacing between the
contour elements
there's a certain critical distance
beyond which you no longer see the
salient contour
and the extent of that uh distance
in the in visual atopic terms when
related back to the cortex
maps precisely exact to the extent of
the horizontal connections
in the visual cortex so either if the
spacing is too great or if the relative
orientation
is too great then you no longer see
these embedded contours
but when you when you allow these
interactions to exist they can
propagate over multiple multiple nodes
in the network
and thereby allowing this phenomenon of
assailancy to extend over large
distances of visual space
but we don't want to suggest that these
interactions
act constitutively so that regardless
of the behavioral context they are
always seeing
but rather they are subject to top-down
influences
of perceptual tasks and i'll show you
how this operates but just to
illustrate how this may be happening in
your visual system if you haven't seen
this image before it's probably
difficult for you to know
what is represented here but if i
allow you to have some measure of
expectation operating
and i show you a more fully rendered
image and then the original image again
you can segment it quite readily now
this
this demonstration will no longer work
for any of you because you'll always
know
you always have the expectation
and but so this uh is also seen
in what we get from these
counter-related responses in the visual
cortex
so if we have the animal
either do the contour detection task or
a
an unrelated task in the opposite hemi
field we see
different degrees of this
counter-related facilitation so about
twice as much facilitation when he's
doing the contour detection task
as when he's doing the other task and we
think
so this so therefore these lateral
interactions are subject to top-down
influences
a perceptual task and we think that it
is related specifically to the task of
contradiction
as opposed to attending to the location
of the contour
because we can see what develops as we
do these
as we train animals progressively on
doing this test so this is worked by the
way that was done by
woo lee where he
looked at the presence of the
counter-related response that is how
much facilitation you get as you
increase the length of the contour
uh when the animal is just trained to
fixate just so he's
not attending to the contour is fixating
and you see no contra-related response
we then train the animal to attend to
the location of the contour only
not doing contour detection he's just
doing the brightness discrimination task
and there's no contour related
facilitation we then train the animal to
do the contour detection task
and you see a substantial degree of
contra-related facilitation
which then is greatly reduced when he
goes back to do the brightness
discrimination task
and under anesthesia there's no
counter-related response so a lot of
these properties
are important to study in awake-behaving
animals
and so the the the take-home message
here
is that this top-down signal carries
information
about the nature of the perceptual task
being performed
not just attention although
bob may want to put it under the uh the
rubric of attentional influences i think
um
it's important to to think about the the
the richness of
of information that is provided in this
top-down fashion
and so we have the the higher order
integrator properties of the neurons
this the the fact that they are subject
to top-down influences
and also now we want to point out that
they are subject to learning and this is
something that we can see
in the uh development of
of the response properties as the animal
is trained on the task
now one in in the
the the phenomenon of learning has been
divided into a number of subtypes
and this is from a a diagram that was
generated by larry squire pointing out
that
memory includes both declarative memory
memories that we're conscious of there's
those
memory of faces facts events objects
and non-declarative memory or implicit
memory memories that we're not conscious
of
and and so this includes habit skill
learning
and in the in the perceptual domain in
the sensory domain it's
the there's a form of learning known as
perceptual learning so it's
the improvement in your ability to do a
discrimination task
by repeated practice of this task
multiple times
so this is one particular task so the
the contra detection task is one
this is another task which we call a
three line bisection task
where we we train subjects to
determine whether the central of three
parallel lines is located near the one
on the left
or the one on the right and there's a
certain offset from the central position
in this task
that is required for you to reliably see
it as one way or the other
but this is a good task to illustrate
some of the salient properties of
perceptual learning
notably its specificity so if i train
you on this three line bisection task
you will be able to see much subtler
differences in this in this offset of
the central line
after a
over a couple of weeks and so this is
the threshold in the task which has been
reduced
in the subject by about a factor of two
but importantly the training on this
task
doesn't transfer to a vernier
discrimination task where the target
line is in the same position the visual
field same orientation
but where the context is changed to a
collinear line as opposed to these two
parallel lines
so there's no significant improvement
here by training on the three-line
bisection task
yet you can then train on the vernier
discrimination test and get considerable
improvement
so whatever the underlying cortical
mechanism is
for this uh for this perceptual learning
has to account for the specificity of
perceptual learning
and specificity is something that had
been
originally described by thorndike in the
early 20th century
and because of that realization
it led to a change in the educational
system in the united states
where it was thought that classical
training that is latin
could be beneficial in learning anything
such as math but what he pointed out and
which then subsequently causes change in
the educational
system in the u.s was that if you wanted
people to learn math you train them on
math you don't train them on latin
so here's this this is a just as a
a stimulus array which i will be uh
referring to later so we can train
animals to do both the three line
bisection task
and the veneer discrimination task and
we see what happens
uh when we present the same set of five
lines
where in one case these three parallel
lines are relevant for the task
and in another case the three collinear
lines are relevant for the task
we'll get back to that in just a second
because i wanted to show you
what happens with perceptual learning on
the task
so as the animal
if you compare the performance of the
animal uh on
on performing these tasks in the first
couple of weeks of training
versus the second couple of weeks of
training you see that there is
a shift upward in what we call the
psychometric curve that is
as you increase the number of lines if
you look at this uh
solid black line uh the the animal
is able to do better at detecting the
presence of the line
with increasing length contours but
after a period of practice
you can do that job with fewer lines and
it's his performance improves and along
with this improvement in the
what we call the psychometric function
there's an improvement in the
neurometric function that is this
contour related facilitation also shifts
up
from this level here to this level here
so it seems that even in the primary
visual cortex
the response properties of neurons are
not fixed but they are capable of
undergoing change as a result of
learning
and experience i
just wanted to point out oh actually
maybe i'll just skip over this because i
want to move on
to another example that shows
what happens in the responses of neurons
when you're not doing a contour
detection test but when you're doing a
shape discrimination task
so here is where we cue the animal to
look for
a particular shape and the the this is
work that was done by justin mcmanus
the shapes include a circle or a
wave-like shape
or a straight line and the question we
asked is
how that influences the shape
selectivity of neurons in the visual
cortex
so after presenting the the contour at
the end of the trial
we have this contour embedded in one of
these complex backgrounds and the
animal's supposed to make his sakai his
eye movement
towards the embedded contour towards
towards the contour that is cue to
detect but before we show these the
target stimulus
we do have a series of presentations
of a set of stimuli where we have a
a line presented within the receptive
field and then move
other line elements outside the
receptive fields different positions and
orientations
to find out what is the optimum shape
that the neuron that we're recording
from is responding to
and then we represent that shape
selectivity on a heat map
where different positions in the map
correspond to different shapes
so the result of this experiment is
illustrated as follows so here
is where we have a neuron that we've
recorded from
while the animal is looking for the
straight line shape
and what we find is that the optimum
stimulus is and the
these heat maps show the the nature of
the stimulus that is um
at that at any particular location by
the this
cartoon of line segments so this is this
shows that
this neuron responds most to a contour
made out of
of of a series of nearly collinear line
segments
but then when you cue the animal to look
for a circle
the optimum shape changes to one
involving more of a
co-circular sequence of line segments
and when he's looking for the wave-like
shape you see
even a more elaborate uh shape uh
selectivity of the neuron where you see
this reversal
in the radius of curvature so the neuron
becomes selective for more of a more of
a wave-like shape
and we see the the entire population of
recorded neurons shifting
from one position in shape space to
another depending on the shape that the
animal is looking for
so once again it shows that the neurons
response characteristics
our selectivity are selected for more
complex geometries
than just short oriented line segments
or even just a
one extended straight line but it
depends on the expectation of the animal
so although we're dealing with fairly
similar stimul simple stimuli here
it's important to point out that the
functional properties of neurons are
constantly shifting
changing according to the expectation of
the animal
we find that it can change on a trial by
trial basis
but it's sort of it's a good question to
ask you know how rapidly
if you could sort of do a a a task
switch in the middle of stimulus
presentation how quickly could you see
it
but at least which we don't know but at
least it seems
if we do two parallel um maps of the
receptive field where on
on on alternate trials we shift the
expectation of the animal
we see that the the the properties
converge to different shapes
on the on the two parallel streams
so yeah so this it's important to point
out that you know i talked about
perceptual learning altering the
response properties of neurons so this
is within
a long-term effect what we could put
under the rubric of
plasticity but the reason that i use the
term the dynamic brain and we talk about
dynamics of circuits
is this is something that doesn't
necessarily require changing
synaptic weights or making new axonal
connections but it's something that
occurs quite rapidly
within the context of an existing
anatomical framework
and so we we were we
we call this more dynamic properties and
and
and as a consequence we think of a
neuron rather than having a fixed
function
as being an adaptive processor capable
of changing its functions
uh in accordance with the needs of the
current perceptual task
and where it gates its inputs where it
can sort of suppress inputs
that are relevant for the task being
performed and
select components of its association
field that are relevant relevant
and thereby taking on these different
selectivities
so this slide is to illustrate what we
think may be happening
at the circuit level where one should
think broadly not just of the intrinsic
connections within a cortical area
but how cortical areas interact with one
another
so the classical view of of cortical
processing
is one of the feed-forward network of of
connections going from the primary
visual cortex
uh through the this ventral pathway for
object recognition going from v1 to v2
to v4
and into the infra-temporal cortex and a
dorsal pathway the
so-called uh vision using vision for
guiding uh movements and that's that's
uh goes into the parietal and
ultimately into the frontal lobes so if
we just consider this pathway
or in fact any other pathway what is
notable is that
for every connection where there's a
feed forward connection
there is a feedback connection so higher
order calorical areas are communicating
some information to the antecedent areas
and we think it's important to consider
the possibility
that the na that the information that is
being communicated in this
feedback fashion is the are these
top-down influences
carrying information about perceptual
task expectation
and attention although uh we are
agnostic as to the possibility of the
participation of other pathways
so in addition to these direct
connections between cortical areas
and i also include this one for kathy
rockland who showed that
um that there's also you can also hop
across
the the entire pathway and and go
directly from the infra-temporal cortex
to
to v1 but it the the
the strongest feedback to v1 is from v2
so
um
so so one can then think that with
the the this set of interactions across
cortical areas
includes the the the map of
the the horizontal circuit so to say uh
that describes the association field
within each cortical area
and that there are these interactions
these these brown lines showing the
feedback connections
between the different cortical areas
that allows
the neurons to gate their inputs across
the whole swath of cortical areas
and that overall uh the the whole set of
cortical areas are changing their state
according to the perceptual test that is
being performed
and the actual functional role of these
areas is changing
in this fashion so we were just
interested in considering how this
process of gating of connections might
be
possible the ideal situation would be if
you could have
an axon from one cortical area contact
the axon terminal
in the antecedent cortical area and turn
it on and turn it off
but that is not an anatomical uh reality
and so we have to think of how this
could happen more at the network level
so valentin pike attempted
to create a biologically realistic model
with neurons with the normal
biophysical properties where we have
this this feedback gain control
that can influence how the neurons
interact with each other
and we extended the network
to include many groups of orientation
columns it's a full set of
orientation columns is what is known as
a hyper column
so here each with these nodes in the
network and these are heavily
interconnected by the horizontal
connections
describing the hor the association field
which are
excitatory connections between columns
as well as inhibitory connections in the
opposite direction
so if you then expand this network up to
include maybe 500
hyper columns you can see how it
operates in
in capturing the contours present in
natural scenes
and so in this image which is a the
often used image for
uh computer vision uh the image of lina
what we find is that when we have this
network operating on the image where we
can include the long-range horizontal
connections and
a strong feedback gain you the the
network captures all the contours
present in the image
and sort of maintains a good dynamic
range between contours of different
uh different contrast or different
strength
and it also replicates what we see
experimentally in the response
properties of neurons
first of all so here is this uh this top
down
input that is reflected in this bright
orange area which then facilitates the
responses of the neurons whose receptor
fields fall
along the contour and inhibits the
responsive neurons in the flanking
regions and this is what we see
with uh when we do large scale
recordings
and it also interestingly replicates we
see in terms of the timing of these
responses so one thing i
i didn't point out to you is that this
counter-related response
is occurs with a certain delay after
the initial visual response and this has
been attributed variously to the
time required for the information to be
fed back from higher order areas or for
with or for information to be propagated
over a
fairly slow horizontal connections but
what this model
shows is that it's due to neither it's
actually due to the time required
for these foreground background
interactions to take place
for the neuron to go from one stable
state for the network to go from one
stable state to another
and so this shows this then in the
in the um in the in the model
which then replicates the delay as well
as the contra related response
for both excitatory and inhibitory
neurons
so the question is can we get any
evidence in support of this idea
that the connectivity within the network
can be dynamically expressed
so to do this an experiment that was
done by nirmala ramalingam
was to embed uh we we embedded these
arrays of electrodes in the visual
cortex
uh chronically so that uh on a
day-by-day basis we could collect
uh the information from hundreds of
neurons simultaneously
and importantly we were able to use a
statistical technique to look at the
interactions between cortical sites
and we could and because we could take
advantage of the functional architecture
of the cortex that is the visiotopic map
of the visual cortex we could
distinguish between
uh cortical sites representing contour
elements that were relevant for the task
being performed
versus those that were tasked irrelevant
so here is where we have this five line
stimulus
that the animal can either be cued to do
the three line bisection task
or the veneer discrimination task so
when he's doing the three line bisection
test these lines are task relevant
these lines are task irrelevant and if
if this is now shows you the recording
sites from the electrode array
each of these points represents each of
the the receptor field position
of the uh at each electrode and these
the these gray uh bars represent the
the stimuli that we use so uh we
have the three different positions
of the parallel lines or five different
positions of the
collinear lines actually there's five
different positions of the of the
parallel lines
so there's there's a total of 25
different stimulus
conditions but on top of that the animal
can be doing either the three-line
bisection task or the vernier
discrimination test
with that with the with the identical
visual stimulus he's just
cued before the stimulus is presented as
to which test he's going to perform
and we can look at the function of the
neuron which is defined in terms of the
tuning characteristics
of the neuron for various attributes in
the stimulus so here we're looking at
how
a neuron respond to a changing offset
of the parallel lines that are
placed outside the receptive field when
the animal is doing
the three-line bisection task where
those three parallel lines are task
relevant we see a substantial degree of
modulation in the response of neurons
but when he's doing the vernier
discrimination task when those three
lines are irrelevant there is much less
modulation in the response of neurons
and this by the way the this this
difference between these two points
occurs from the very outset of the
response of the neuron so here
where we don't have this complex
background uh
the the contextual influence arises from
the very first
output of the of the primary visual
cortex
and so one can do this by one can see
this both with recordings
based on spiking activity of
individually recorded neurons
or based on local field potentials which
reflect the
combined activity of hundreds of
thousands of neurons at the same time
and there too we see this differential
tuning depending on which task the
animal's performing
and over the population this can be
expressed in terms
of mutual information that is there's
more information
uh in the conveyed by the response of
the neuron
relative to the attributes in the task
that are
that are relevant for that task uh when
he's doing that task
compared to when he's doing a different
test so there's there's there's a shift
in the amount of
in in the in the kind of information
that is conveyed
by the neuron and so one could imagine
that well
maybe one way this is done would be to
just turn off the activity of the
neurons that are irrelevant to the task
but that's not what happens there these
are the
uh responses that one measures at the
flanking sites and there's no difference
in the responses depending on the task
the animal's performing
but rather there is a change in the way
in which these sites interact
and we can measure this by one of two
techniques either
cross-correlation analysis where we look
at the relative timing of spikes between
pairs of neurons between the two
different cortical sites
and uh when the two are interacting when
there's a neural interaction there's a
peak in the correlogram
which is shown here and when they're
independent when there's no
neural interaction the correlogram is
flat
and so what we find is that between the
two sites
with the same amount of spikes occurring
between the neurons
you'll either get an interaction
occurring a peak in the correlogram
or a flat correlogram dependent on
the perceptual task that the animal is
performing
remember these the stimulus is identical
so the only thing that is changing
is what the animal is thinking about
what what task he's performing
and you can see this change in
interaction also with
another measure lfp coherence so we look
at how
the local field potentials either
co-vary or or
vary independently and interestingly
if we record from two sites that are
representing the the central line and
the flanking line
in the three line bisection task you see
much stronger lfp coherence
when he's doing the three-line bisection
test then when he's doing
the irrelevant test the vernier
discrimination task
but curiously we see the opposite
relationship
when he's doing the when we're looking
we're recording from the collinear sites
when he's doing the vernier
discrimination test compared with the
uh three line bisection tests so there's
much stronger
coherence when when they are tasked
irrelevant so what could account for
that
we think it has to do with the
perceptual strategy and going back to
the work of the gestalt psychologist
and that is that the three-line
bisection task is more
akin to a grouping task based on
proximity
and the vernier discrimination task is
actually a segmentation task where
you're trying to
separately separate the collinear line
segments
from one another to be able to see this
offset between them
so what happens if we look at the
coherence between
co-linear sites and a test that involves
perceptual group
grouping namely the contour detection
task
and what we see is that in fact so here
is the the experimental design where
the animal is fixating here and he's
either going to do the
contour detection task as shown here or
the three line bisection task where
he's not paying attention to the
embedded contour
and what we see is that there is
stronger coherence
between collinear sites when he's doing
the contour detection task
than when he's doing the other task or
when he's just fixating and not doing
either task
so and another interesting thing to
point out
is that these changes in coherence
are not dependent on the stimulus but
dependent on the task so even
so we see this difference in coherence
before the stimulus is turned on
so the stimulus is turned on here but
the animal has already been
queued earlier as to which tests he's
going to perform and you can see these
differences in coherence
happening and sort of setting the
cortical state
to be ready to analyze the visual
stimulus in a way that is appropriate
for the the stimulus that um that for
the test that he's performing
also uh there's some interesting
features about how
the the population activity carries
information
about the uh about the stimulus
above and beyond what you see in these
changes in tuning
but i i actually unfortunately nancy's
not here today but i
just wanted to to bring this slide up
which shows that
that brings up the idea that
that because the properties of neurons
are not fixed and they can change
their their functional role within a
broad range of
of of a broad range of functions
this sort of raises the possibility that
when you're doing mri
fmri it can explain for why you see
uh a lot of seemingly unrelated
functions
in the same cortical region so now
to end with i wanted to tell you to
shift from the idea of short-term
dynamics to long-term plasticity
so here we've sort of painted a picture
that there's this existing anatomical
framework
that that neuron neurons can multiplex
their function or change their function
depending on this top-down signal which
we think
involves an interaction between cortical
feedback
and intrinsic cortical circuits but we
also know
that experience can induce long-term
changes in cortical function we saw it
in the example of perceptual learning
but we've also been working with another
model of experience dependent plasticity
but now keep this in mind keep in mind
that this is in the adult animal
so from the work that torsten and david
did many years ago
they found that there was a critical
period in postnatal life
during which the neurons could change
their functional properties
and circuits namely thalamo-cortical
circuits could change
as a result of alteration altering the
balance of input between the two eyes
but this should now show some
experiments
that illustrate another set of
properties and another class of cortical
connections that retain the capacity for
plasticity throughout life
and what we've done here is to do a
rather
extreme version of altering visual
experience which is to make a
focal retinal lesion binocularly in
corresponding positions in the two eyes
so what this does is this removes visual
input
from a well-circumscribed region of the
visual cortex
and so the expectation would be that
after you make those lesions that area
of cortex
is silenced for the rest of the life of
the animal
but what we found quite to the contrary
is that neurons whose receptor fields
were originally within their
part of the retina that later became
part of the retinal scotoma the blind
spot that we induced with a with a laser
they they shift their receptor fields to
intact regions of the retina and so this
is
this is the the receptive field
positions that we see
uh when we implant electrodes
uh we these use these chronically
implanted electrode arrays and by the
way the advantage of this
approach to to looking at the phenomenon
is that
you no longer are subject to selecting
the few active neurons that are that are
still there after all the rest of them
have been silenced
the electrode is fixed we haven't moved
it around to find an active neuron
we find that 90 of the cortical sites
recover visually driven activity
aft within a period of weeks following
the lesion
so what this means is that
this is this represents the the lesion
part of the retina and the area of
cortex that
received input from the lesion part of
the retina so that initially
that area of cortex is silenced but over
a period of time
there's a shrinkage in the
representation of the lesion part of the
retina
and an expansion in the representation
of the surrounding part of the retina
and we think this may have a a a
a functionally a useful function for r
for visually visual recovery after
lesions of the retina
and this is a a model that shows what
might one might expect to happen
in a case of macular degeneration so
this is the most common form
of blindness in the adult and
if you were to sort of present
an image to that you had to look through
one of the
corrupted retina such that you have with
macular degeneration where there are
regions of geographic atrophy uh and in
between
the salt and pepper loss of
photoreceptors
uh you would have difficulty in figuring
out what the image was if you were
if you had to look at it through that
retina but
if you allow the shifting receptor
fields where they maintain
their original line label for their
original position in visual space
that then allows a process of perceptual
fill-in
so the locally the image may be somewhat
corrupted
globally you can make out the the image
quite well
and so we think this the that the
this plasticity which may use the
pre-existing association field which
operates for contour integration
and and shape discrimination uh
throughout life
can be reinvoked for functional recovery
after uh lesions of the central nervous
system
such as what may occur with stroke or
neurodegenerative disease
and to look at what the circuit
changes are that underlie this
phenomenon we used a technique
of two-photon microscopy which we
developed for
large animal imaging with winford dank
and
what the technique involves if you if
you're
probably i'm talking to the cognoscenti
here but
it is a technique that allows you to see
with high resolution
fine structural details of neurons in
the below the cortical surface down to a
depth of up to
500 microns or so so we can image
neurons throughout the superficial
cortical layers
we label them with a fluorescent tag so
by infecting them with adeno-associated
virus containing the green fluorescent
protein gene and after
allowing enough time for that gene to be
expressed we can then
see these neurons in their great detail
and i'll show you an image in a second
both the the full dendritic and axonal
arbors of these neurons
and in in the in the context of the
retinal lesion experiment what we do is
make
several injections of the of the virus
and along a line
of injection sites and then after
um and then we we can image the pattern
of projections
uh from the injection site into one side
or
or another of the line and then after
getting a baseline map
of the circuit in the in the visual
cortex we make a retinal lesion where
the lesion boundary
is placed right to one side of that uh
instead of
injection so that the projections to
this side
correspond to the lesion projection zone
and the lesion
and the the image the the projections to
this side
correspond to projections in normal
visual cortex
so first of all this shows you what the
two photon images look like so this is
in the living brain
uh you can this is in the injection site
you can you can make out
the spines from the the dendrites of
neurons
and you can see these clusters of axon
collaterals i notice this sort of
blebbing
along the the course of the axon so
these are known as axonal boutons
and they're the site of presynaptic uh
these are the pre-synaptic sites along
the axon
now when we don't do any lesion just to
look look from week to week
at the at these axonal boutons we see
that they are constantly disappearing
and appearing at a rate of about seven
percent per week
so this is this rather extraordinary uh
phenomenon
that the the the circuits within our
brains are not fixed but the synapses
are constantly undergoing this churning
um throughout life and we don't know
whether there may be some synapses that
are more relatively stable but at least
over the period of time that we imaged
we saw this turnover
occurring at that rate you'd see you
know over three weeks 21
new boutons and and 21 disappearing
but but but at least but but without
making a lesion
the branching pattern seems to be
relatively stable
so this is what we see when we make a
retinal lesion and look in the lesion
projection zone
so again we've made an injection to one
side and we're looking at the
lesion projection zone at different time
points before
on the day of and after we make the
lesion
and what was quite extraordinary is that
on the same day that we make the lesion
we see this extraordinary outgrowth of
new axons
so these yellow traced axons are the
ones that have grown
relative to the previous imaging point
and the red ones are the ones that
disappear
uh relative to the previous imaging
point and you can see that on a week by
week basis
there is constant new outgrowth and
pruning
occurring in parallel with a net
increase in the density of these
horizontal connections in the lesion
projection zone
over the the imaging period and we think
this
then corresponds very closely to what we
see in terms like
when we record with these arrays to the
rather rapid initial
uh uh change in the in the receptive
fields of neurons that we see on the
same
day as we make in the lesion and the
eventual remapping of the visual cortex
that occurs
uh invading this the central of the
towards towards the center of the lesion
projection zone
and we can compare what happens to these
excitatory
connections to what happens with
inhibitory connections
by using a virus that that solumeric had
constructed
that is under the control of the gad65
promoter so we can then selectively
image
inhibitory neurons and this just shows
that
by by co-labeling uh
neurons with the gad 65 aav virus
and a cocktail of calcium binding
proteins which
labels 99 of inhibitory neurons that we
see co-localization
uh and therefore we think that we are
selectively labeling inhibitory neurons
and this shows that you get a similar
sort of
efflorescence and pruning of exons of
inhibitory neurons within the lesion
projection zone
we have made a similar series of
experience experiments in a mouse model
that allows us to more uh
take to take a detailed look at the
molecular mechanisms underlying this
plasticity
and so uh this one is one involving the
whisker barrel system of the mouth so
the the the the positions of the
whiskers
are mapped in the somatosensory cortex
of the mouse
in terms of a series of rows of barrels
and what
and one can induce plasticity and we can
create a lesion projection zone
by plucking the whiskers so we pluck the
d and e rows of whiskers
and what happens is that over a period
of time these
these barrels which are initially
silenced then become responsive to input
from the c
row of whiskers so there's again a
remapping that is taking place
and we can see that this remapping is
associated with a sprouting
of excitatory connections into the
deprived barrels
and a sprouting of inhibitory neurons
whose axons are within the
who are resident within their private
barrels towards their the source of this
new excitatory input which we think is
useful for
maintaining a balance between excitation
so here's the
balance of excitation inhibition so
here's the sprouting of excitatory input
into the barrels
and here's the sprouting of inhibitory
connections from the barrels
and and we can then see what the
molecular mechanism may be and this is
something we've seen both in the monkey
visual cortex following retinal lesions
and in the mouse somatosensory cortex
following whisker plucking that these
these orange
labeled neurons are ones expressing bdnf
and the brain derived neurotrophic
factor
and so this and these are local
localized
to the deprived barrels and we think
therefore is the stimulus for the
sprouting of connections into the lesion
projection zone
but also keep in mind that we see this
phenomenon of pruning of connections
and this is and for this we've looked
uh from after being inspired by some of
the work of mark tessie levine
we've looked at the apoptotic pathway so
a
a signaling pathway that is involved
in cell death early in development
does not lead to cell death in the adult
but
as i'll show you is responsible for
pruning of connections
so and this is where it's useful to have
a mouse model from time to time until
uh until bob comes along with the
the monkey knockouts that we need um
if we knock out uh so there's there's an
interaction between the the
neurotrophin signaling pathway and
a receptor known as death receptor six
this guy here
and that leads to the activation of
caspases
which then leads to accidental
retraction so if we knock out
death receptor 6 so this is what we see
normally
there's this sprouting of new
connections in yellow pruning of old
connections
in red that occurs progressively from
day to day
in the mouse somatosensory cortex but
that pruning entirely disappears in the
back's knockout
and so it appears that this pathway may
be
useful for uh the sculpting of
connections
and interestingly we see what seems to
be even a heightened
outgrowth of connections when we make
these knockouts along the um
along this pathway so um
so i to summarize um
there seems to be different levels of
dynamics or plasticity
that occurs within the visual cortex and
this is seen not just in higher order
cortical
areas that are thought to represent
declarative memory but
is a dynamic process that can even
affect neurons at the very earliest
stages
of visual cortical processing and one
may be concerned that if the primary
sensory area
is so dynamic why doesn't that disrupt
your ability
to uh to see things in a stable visual
environment
and the answer to that is because of the
fact that the the the alterations in
function
are only seen when you're doing the
train task
so these properties are just available
in a just-in-time
fashion that that they that when you're
doing
a contour detection task or a three line
bisection task the neuron
the the learned properties are manifest
um
only when you're doing the task so that
this this top down interaction
is required for for both the encoding of
the learned information
and for its recall and
uh since uh i'm in this this context of
a general lecture
i like to speculate more broadly that
this may
raise a general theory of of brain
interactions of the circuit mechanisms
of brain function
that every cortical area
has represented within it an association
field
and by these top-down interactions
neurons can select components of their
association fields and take on different
functional roles
in ways that are appropriate for the
task at hand
suppressing task irrelevant information
and
gating allowing the input from task
relevant information
and this idea of interactions between
global cortical circuits and local
circuits
this idea that feedback gates the local
circuits is something that may operate
not just in cortico-cortical
interactions
but in interactions between the
hippocampus and the in the cortex where
the hippocampus can be thought of
as being a pointer for linking bits of
information across the
cortical maps where there
it can be used for more rapid learning
but also
its role can be decoupled after
consolidation
and for interactions between the stride
the striatum
and the say the motor cortex or or
prefrontal cortex
where again the street item would serve
a pointer function
for sequencing operations that are
occurred that
that occur with with habit learning and
so
we think this may be a sort of a useful
theoretical framework
to think about how circuits can
contribute to
cortical function and for the dynamics
of cortical function
and so i just wanted to acknowledge a
number of my collaborators this is
sort of historically long list but
in particular woo lee has been had
pioneered in doing some of the most
wonderful
experiments where we look at the
properties of neurons
in the monkey in different behavioral
contexts
pike had done this very nice
computational model which we hope to
extend
in the future to see how we can imagine
how the dynamics
in input selection can occur for more
specific tasks
and uh of course uh torsten was involved
early on
in identifying the this important class
of connections which we think
are playing a critical role in mediating
the association field
and its gating and we have um
enjoyed the the input from gerald
westheimer and doing
the the psychophysical experiments from
winfred dank
and designing and building a new uh
two-photon imaging system and shimon
almond for some of the modeling work
that we've done so it's it's really
it's sort of a it
it takes a community to actually
successfully pursue these
these experiments that have to be done
in a in a in a highly collaborative and
interdisciplinary way
so i thank you all for for coming and
open for questions